brings me a to a topic I'm very
passionate about which is birth control
options that are available to women I
can't I can't believe that we don't have
better options for birth control they
all drive me crazy what do you want what
do you take in you have an IUD come up
here we're gonna take it out I hate this
product is yours plastic or metal yours
is plastic okay well she's got the
McDonald's toy in her body right now
most of them are metal some are plastic
most of them are a little piece of metal
they put inside your uterus I'm like I
don't want metal inside my body I don't
want to be going through airport
security and having the guys behind the
x-ray machine like oh look at this slut
coming through
bitch how to put a tin can up in there
stop all that sperm no I don't want
mental ate my body what if there's a
storm guys I can't make it tonight it's
raining I hate this product mostly
because like they would never develop
that product for men that would never be
a product on the market for men right
you and I would never be dating and
you'd be like babe what should we do for
birth control I'd be like I have an idea
how about we take a metal rod and put it
up your dick hole and leave it there for
about five years or until it gets
infected is that a good idea I hate this
product and it has like three pages of
side effects I can't believe that they
release a product with three pages of
side effects I'm like go back it's not
ready
I looked at the side effects for the IUD
it was like migraines abdominal pain and
depression I was like I might as well
have a fucking kid
[Applause]
what about you what are you up to the
pill do you know which one No
this fucking generation man they don't
even they'll just put anything in their
mouth they don't even care
like I'll poison fine you don't even do
you know what color the box is at least
it's pink motherfuckers I hate that ties
me nuts like that is so everything about
the pill is insulting to me the fact
they make the box pink the pill is pink
as if all women just like love pink and
if the pill being pink affects your
decision of whether you're gonna take it
or not that means you're ten years old
and you're too young to be on birth
control anyway okay second of all if you
want me to remember to take my pill
every day don't make a pink make it in
the shape of tiny crying babies I can't
stand the pill I actually just read this
article about how the pill works
basically the way the pill works is it
tricks your body into thinking you're
pregnant your brain starts producing the
same neuro chemicals and hormones as if
your body is pregnant you know this you
watch Oprah good girl
and then you start being attracted to
more alpha males their pheromones start
smelling stronger and you're attracted
to alpha males the kind of man that
could protect your future offspring the
problem is that in modern times alpha
males are signified by tattoos and
motorcycles which explains why I've been
dating such assholes since I'm 15 years
old the way that it works is that I meet
a nice sensitive guy I want to share my
future with I start taking birth control
to plan it and then all of a sudden I
only can have an orgasm if I smell Axe
body spray that's not fair
and it's an example of how biology has
not yet caught up with modern technology
it's the 21st century
I don't need an alpha male to protect me
we have street lights okay we have alarm
systems
I don't need an alpha male I need a guy
with fast Wi-Fi so I can Google can I
take Dan X while pregnant
that's my baby's father
[Music]
[Applause]